uh jj ali miranda but we're going to
have him analyze this position with us
because we're running out of time and we
don't want to break the
flow of the game but jj welcome welcome
to the studio congrats on your win a
very topsy-turvy game
uh topsy-turvy tournament i would say
yes definitely uh but a nice nice to
pick up away tell us your first instinct
on what's going on here in the position
on the board a takes b5 boom
that was played yeah yeah
wow and g6 h4
yeah it looks very unclear but well the
question is right now is the white king
getting checkmated
is the black king getting checkmated
that is also a very good question
um
let's say it's equal yeah that's the
practical answer it's always equal is
this what i think by the way you are
definitely correct because this is what
i teach them
the engine says zero zero zero zero zero
i mean when both sides don't have time
these positions can get super
complicated like yesterday i was hoping
for something like this and i was
actually lost so
and i thought it could be double edged
and if the engine is giving zeros
i guess it's it can go either way but
so it's equal objectively but
who has the better side of equality
right now is the question
from my perspective is white
because right now it doesn't feel like
you have a good way to create anything
around my king i really like this move
gtx h4 yeah it's a very practical move
right you just get rid of hg forever but
more importantly it gives the g3 square
to this queen and suddenly you can
imagine many variations in which queen
g3 queen g7 will be devastating i
actually haven't seen which lines but
actually queen g3 is a devastating
threat because king f8 i have bishop a3
and i think i start uh giving you
checkmate
uh and i assume that if you ever have to
interpose the bishop that it's not
actually on its ideal diagonal although
who knows maybe it is okay so right now
i guess we should go with queen to h1
play king d2 queen h2 and now if you go
to c3 i'm going to take advantage of the
fact that you in fact took on h4 and
opened up that diagonal so now my queen
on h2 supports uh this retreat with the
knight to f4 so if you want to go queen
e2 knight f4 you mean sorry no no if you
go queen to e2 i'm going to start
looking for some extra tracks maybe
queen 2 d6
queen d6 maybe
no it's really weird because
i actually feel i'm getting kind of
mated here
but
so if you go king to c3 i think
e4 you know i was thinking this is
checkmate but then i realized it wasn't
and it actually don't see it at all
knight f4
knight f4 maybe just bring the other
piece to the attacker
yeah
d3
yeah this is over yeah so king c3 on the
board uh this is the current position
does he have b4 here
and then queen b2
does he have b
that's a very good question right
before check
you might as well take what else well he
definitely has that and the question is
uh does white has a group takes seven
seven yeah there's no more chat this is
your only chance right there's no no
check on the g file there's this check
doesn't really help me because queen g7
at the very least by v bishop g4 is also
good but rook takes c7
and
what a mess and it the evaluation hasn't
really changed yeah the evaluation is
this is a mess and and we continue he
actually didn't play
before he actually just brought the
knight back
also makes sense but allows queen g1
yeah it does allow queen g1 with the
simplification take it
i think you have to take it right take
the queen trade i think you have to take
the queen trade
i mean this king is just becoming a bit
too vulnerable the knight is finally
joining the fray with the move knight d5
uh check on the next move by the way uh
knight to f4 was played with three
seconds on the clock
so
again big decisions you need to allow
yourself to have more time on the clock
that's the practical and i think the
lower this gets on time the more likely
you are to play queen g one and so you
want yeah yeah you have almost sure
you'll play queen g one
he has to win
yeah i think yeah quinji one played
takes i you have to take and i guess you
take
and
you still have a few moves to make time
control but
i i
there's no real danger here for white at
all then the minor piece is not going to
mate you the question is do you have
winning chances here well the position
got simplified we're going to let the
players think about this one i'm sure
they're going to reach time control
without any problems but jj let's go
into your game because
you saw this scandinavian on the board
and you immediately launched an attack
with b4 was that preparation or like
no honestly i was just in the mood to
play some gambits today the usual the
usual regardless of what opening it was
and when he played the scandinavian i
was a little annoyed that i didn't get
what i wanted so i was like okay let's
just at least have some fun and played
before
okay now tell me did alejandro teach you
this
i would never teach such moves i mean it
was an over the board decision to be
honest because i was like if i play the
main lines it's going to be boring so
i'll just at least have some fun let's
go for the kill i like it yeah
yeah and it's it's if you got everything
you wanted out of the opening uh g6 i
don't understand like
maybe it makes sense but to me it was a
bit awkward
yeah and it seems like you got almost a
winning position
also f6 was shocking but like i don't
know if i
had something better i think i played
like king h1 queen e2 it was a bit too
slow um
probably makes
not
much sense but
i don't know i thought it was safe to
play king h1 actually bishop this is a
very nice win but bishop jade is winning
i know that you never look at these
moves i looked at it i just didn't see
how it wins after because you have to
take with the king right yes if you take
with the rook then you have bishop eight
six and then yeah seven knight g5 right
yeah and if king yi knight knight d6
yeah
so
what happens if you take with the king
in this position
yeah i don't know i couldn't see it so i
was like
if i don't see it i shouldn't give up my
light squared bishop i'm just going to
cheat yes please yeah engine says bishop
h6 plus 6.
bishop i mean yeah but like how do you
guarantee it during a game i guess
yeah it makes sense yes when you know it
when it's plus six
yeah i i guess if black has no moves
here right just paralyzes paralyzed
completely and even this doesn't help
you
and i guess the key point is that if you
go queen to h5 you have knight takes f6
or
oh this is nice yeah this is nice yeah
you just even if you take and you take
this black if i saw this i would play it
for sure yeah and
if you uh play king takes here
and here as christian was mentioning
then knight f6
it's a pretty nice line uh black's
getting pretty much it in every
variation
yeah this is checkmate for sure
and sticks with the pod and if you take
with the pawn
then i think you just go check pick up
the rook and pick up just a regular
position and then you take on b7 at the
end although you have i can take on c8
now and you can think of the idea
you can take on c8 and just win a work
on at least the rook
and call it a day yeah that would have
been nice i could have been done like
two hours ago right but yeah
but you wouldn't be here with us in the
studio so that's why you took your sweet
time
yeah and i mean i was thinking these
moves were logical but apparently not so
goes out the window when you talk to
computers
yeah
uh
when were you absolutely sure that you
were winning
uh pretty much never until the last move
i think
like he was getting low on time so i
knew he was going to blend or something
and then around here i thought i was
having sufficient counter play for like
the two pawns and i was confident he was
going to blunder he had no time so and
he did blunder but
not the best technique but i mean with
no time also i probably don't need
the best technique just wanted to be
practical and that's it well certainly a
nice victory how do you rate your
tournament so far
i mean it has a lot of ups and downs i'm
not like super happy about it but also
like at least i'm playing some fun chess
so it's
it's entertaining at least some fun
chess for sure well thank you for
joining us uh jj certainly a fun game to
watch it did keep us captivated for the
better part of half an hour here in the
studio
as soon as we started the program
congratulations thank you
all right let's move on